[Music]
in a crib across news no submitted by
waiting for baby bear me too buddy
trust me makes the best value in the one
side of us is like just hold on for
another couple months wait what he
talked about it and then there's another
side of us that were super curious what
he looks like oh I can't wait to see
whoa yeah I'm excited for that I don't
want to wait I want it out of my body a
20 year old says he is making over six
thousand dollars a month
farming garages gee why the [ __ ] do you
need Cochran is for like inside I can
take food cat food yeah I'll be in pet
food really chuckles lizard first I'd
smear all those mice you know they don't
really specify in this article but yeah
they just say that it's pepper or are
the exotic cockroaches that people buy
because I know there's different kinds
of cockroaches oh there's like the big
ones and the [ __ ] they also mention
that people buy them because though this
takes place in China and so they have a
[ __ ] ton of free cockroach I'm just
kidding China I'm kidding whatever ass
comment section just wait love you China
it's just a joke so you're saying um
that there's also parts of China where
cockroaches are its delicacies Allah by
whole [ __ ] what yeah you do
that
no okay cuz I watched advice documentary
where they were showing like all the new
like trendy ways to eat bugs and stuff
like that rnd what the [ __ ] would it
become much right coming back I guess I
guess some cultures though that eat bugs
like on a regular usage already
well hipsters just take what's been
happening in the different cultures and
then they kind of start doing it right
because they were showing it in like
sauces and stuff they would put like
silkworm grubs and stuff like that and
just and I'm like alive like a silkworm
people
right but they had fried dishes too and
stuff but yeah I was like a whole thing
and then they had like these giant farms
of like roaches and everything I have
heard that things the way like
humanity's going where we're just super
populated at one point it's gonna be
hard to consume the food that we already
used to these days and so they're
looking at insects for protein sources
awesome vegetarian here I come if they
make insect chips and a taste bomb I
wouldn't be opposed to iam because
they're high in protein yeah remember
those crickets that we were like
challenged and then I was I actually I
think I could get used to this because
it's just like shrimp trips like chips
but they're like they chirp yes for this
student yeah six thousand so he's a
twenty year old named Tom and so I
didn't make that kind of money when I
was twenty
yes tongue they don't mention what what
he has they're just saying that at one
point he was buying a lot of cockroaches
to feed his pet and in order to save
money he decided to try to form his own
cockroaches and that's when he met a
cockroach farmer named Chad and so two
of them teamed up but yeah so the two of
them teamed up and they they have their
own cockroach farm where they make $6
what do they do just throw the trash on
the floor wait for the cockroaches to
pour yeah I was actually curious to they
don't really go into detail how they
apartment but they're saying that he has
about thirty to forty thousand cockroach
oh my god after six months of starting
the farm John the six months of them
pictures you have cockroach all of the
homies that's kind of funny that's like
me and Bart but like instead of comedy
in YouTube it's cockroaches so this is
ty my name is Tong I like a car garage I
don't know
today but here's another photo you know
it's interesting - Tong is actually
afraid of cockroaches realize over his
spirit likes money desire for money is
over is fear Kagura yeah I want to get
rid of that [ __ ] I know what that feels
like what feels like like I'm scared of
heights but someone gave me a ten
million dollar I'll jump out of a plane
like that skydiving roller coaster
whatever you name it I'm down you mean
to tell me you make six thousand a week
on a cockroach
okay fear factor here I come it's a
month oh I thought it was a week I still
a lot for but it was between two people
so is it really gonna say like it was
cut what if the other guy is also making
six thousand dollars and it's the dollar
go a long way they're probably balling
out of control there yeah why has
cockroach groupies and stuff fans
oh no he's probably that Mark Zuckerberg
of cockroaches out there sure he does
people love Technic Technic yeah yeah
detective nowadays they got tech
groupies yeah yep like that one movie
about the Facebook's the social
experiment asian girls white nerds and
white nerds love asian girls
that's like the match made in heaven
that's a bridge marry to that Chinese
chick yeah I don't know about this [ __ ]
though like that's dope I I'm so proud
of you guys like dope you found a
business and something that none of us
would find a business in but what this
is low real estate farming keep in mind
yes because try to find 10,000 cows and
you're gonna need like hundreds of
thousands of acres
what do cockroach eat besides the
garbage oh okay that's it lots of
carnage interesting though that they're
saying that cockroach farming is a
booming industry wide enough but is so
weird maybe they don't have the same
like idea about cockroach the way we do
because you know how we got like
crickets is our pet food you know like
Oh
crickets maybe mealworms but we don't
use cockroach because cockroach is the
dirty dirty bugs well apparently they
also use it like they also crush up
cockroaches in China and they put them
in pills and then people take them I
used to take gotta tell me this [ __ ] no
I used to drink a ground-up wasp yeah so
I'll go with my mom's like that herbal
store like I have a cold or something
and instead of just getting like naik
well we go to the herbal store and this
[ __ ] old geezer comes out with
the old school scale right so it's not
even a digital scale it's like this
scale that's made out of a [ __ ] ivory
tusk and then there's like this Brad and
he grabs like a handful of dried wasps
and you see where this thing dangles and
then my mom would go home and make soup
out of that and I would drink it well
that tastes like [ __ ] oh okay did you
like like stinky tofu [ __ ] no like I'm
talking about the bitterness of coffee
times 10,000 oh did it work right away
because if it didn't that sucks all
right she trying to cure I don't get the
disease yeah well that he had as a child
why do Chinese people gotta ate
everything that moves yeah it's it was
pretty nasty it was like dark big really
really really bitter I'm with you I had
to drink soup like that for a good three
months and my cold never went away I
don't know what it was a moment like
here you should drink it cuz I heard
what the doctor said
Elvis [ __ ] witch doctors man's
qualification it was a doctor no check
my pulse I'd be like God ain't no doctor
like telling my mom these things are all
your daughter's bodies like three too
hot like here's some medicine and like
don't have like you know like like
before the herbal medicines a highway
like pieces of antler yeah
there's like an alert dates like there's
routes yeah there's all sorts of [ __ ]
and it's like it becomes really bitter
so like all you have to just put a tree
in a pot and you boil it dad yeah so for
three months and I was still sick my mom
was like I don't get it like let's go
back to doctor like mom can I just just
go to a regular doctor get a pill yeah
if you ever see a doctor in a garage go
somewhere else
[ __ ] Chinese emperors die because
they're like you need a drink mercury
homie something's [ __ ] up in your
heart and Chee right here so you need to
drink mercury so they she drank some
mercury for [ __ ] immortal your
immortality you know like you crazy
afterlife Real Talk though like if you
presented me with Eastern and Western
medicine because I'm so used to not
taking Western or just medicine in
general I think I would probably
gravitate a little bit more towards
Eastern because it's natural and it's
not as scary like you know the
ingredients what the [ __ ] is take a look
scary to what extent though to what
extent would you go like holistic like
treatments over look I think once my
body's just it like three months later
probably to Western because it's like
okay I tried my best to do the holistic
you know organic route let me try some
Western chemicals is there a thing where
they actually merge the two there is a
thing just people trying to do that for
years they've been trying to them
recently my brother took his fiancee
over to that doctor that I went to when
I was younger
why would you let it because I wasn't in
jail yeah I wasn't there okay bar
license no there I know that they have
like like another guy's garage
our national license please people it's
really loose it's like a licensing test
or something yeah yeah what the [ __ ] is
in the Chinese Wizard of America what
kind of degree is the one that I used to
go to with my mom he so he always has
like a white coat like a doctor and he
had so he prescribes you takes your
pulse and all that he has all these
drawers of all these herbs and stuff the
other side he sells pagers pagers and
calling hearts the help is a while ago
so now like they have the option of
whether you want to boil it or you just
want to take this pill that has
everything just the pill the boiling
smells like yeah but the fiance didn't
know so she chose what to say Oh make it
into soup and then my brother's like no
she'll take the pill hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just kidding
news and if there's a story that you
guys want us to talk about go ahead down
into our description box below and
there's a link there where you can
submit articles for the next video click
right up here
[Music]